so today we're going to be talking about
airsoft guns uh in the past we've
actually mentioned that we've been using
airsoft guns for videos for a long time
but only recently have we actually
started playing for airsoft games
actually i use a gas gun it's a gas
submachine gun unlike electric guns gas
guns have like an instant response
basically when you pull the trigger it's
all like just pressure so it just
instantly starts firing
with an electric gun you have to we have
you essentially have to wait for the
little electric motor to wind up and so
you get small delays when you start
finding your weapon yeah so as you see
here these are the guns that we actually
use for most of our games these are like
my two guns this is sam's this is jake's
yeah actually of all the guns we have
very few of them actually like work
because we kind of mess them up when we
make videos so we have like a couple
special ones that still work just about
10 minutes away from us is evite which
is the
nation's biggest airsoft retailer so we
cruise down there we know the guys and
they help us out with uh our props and
costumes for our videos but also our
actual personal airsoft guns these guys
are having all the fun running around
with their sweet lightweight
single-handed submachine guns like being
the action stars while i'm hanging back
just like blinking at guys from a window
so i decided it's time for me to go and
build the craziest
close quarters submachine gun i possibly
could hey fellas hey we're recording
the thing is you know we do a lot of
action pieces
and playing airsoft has actually made us
notably better at directing gun
telling the actors how to move or when
we're in it ourselves how we move you
get all these little nuances of like how
you pose and how you aim and like
what's dynamic with your movements and
it's the equivalent of like you're doing
a martial arts scene it looks way better
if you hire somebody who actually knows
how to fight even if the martial arts
scene is ridiculous and has
you know no grounding in reality still
getting somebody that knows how to throw
a punch you can at least inform some of
their decisions with that makes that
much better and it's the same thing with
airsoft we're not soldiers neither
salmon or i've ever served in the
military so we're not gonna you know
ever pretend to be
of that level
but if you want to have any hope at like
trying to have sweet tactics in our
stuff
you know the next best thing we can get
to is to incorporate some of the airsoft
where are you gonna get a pirate ship
we're working on that okay hey guys i'm
here at evike with matt how's it going
you might recognize matt from all the
various e-bike videos reviews and other
fun things you guys have done anyways
let's uh should we head inside yeah
sweet i'm excited
this place is like the real life
white matrix here where like all the
weapons live in that's kind of what we
were going for with the gun wall we
wanted you to feel like it had just like
rushed past you and you had this huge
selection of things
and we've got just about every gun that
we retail on the wall we even have
vending machines for bbs
oh wow basically everything you need for
an action movie yeah in building this
gun we're going to use something called
a polar star which is a rather fancy
airsoft system that's going to make for
an incredibly high-powered gun can you
maybe tell us a little bit about like
what's going to make this gun special
compared to like just a regular airsoft
gun sure okay there are two systems for
powering uh traditional airsoft guns you
have a gas system the gas system holds
gas in the magazine
and you're limited by you know the
volume of the magazine for the amount of
gas and you're also limited speed wise
uh by how quickly the piston system
inside can cycle to allow you know rate
of fire electrics work a little bit
different instead of using
gas to move the entire system you use
the battery a set of gears and a piston
again you're limited by the size of your
magazine the charge of your battery and
how quickly the gears and piston can
cycle in theory the polar star system
uses the best of both worlds the system
itself is actually powered by an
electronic solenoid two solenoids and a
high pressure air tank that gives you an
almost limitless supply of air depending
on the size of your tank
and of course because you're using
standard electric magazines you can hold
as many rounds as that magazine can hold
so do you think we can make a one-handed
gun that's basically shooting a laser
beam of plastic bbs oh yes very much so
well that's the idea
yeah so i mean all that's left to do is
to uh to get started building sweet
let's do it
okay
yeah here we are so far
it's looking
pretty sweet
it'll be fine it's gonna be incredible a
little bit did you shoot first nico
always
it's pretty crazy
it's gonna hurt
just a little bit
all right so we're about to step into
the test firing range to test out the uh
i don't know i'll go over the name for
it later now i'll call it the laser beam
um we're gonna go test with the laser
beam
[Music]
uh i think i'm gonna make a lot of
people angry at me when i shoot them way
too many times to serve
i just like why did you shoot me like 50
times i'll be like sorry
uh
i won't do that this time so we're wired
up to a scuba tank testing this out for
the first time got a mid cap mate here
so i can feed better
it's crazy
i'm gonna try to cut the head off this
cardboard target we'll see if it happens
we got ready
it's gonna reload
[Music]
sweet
it was literally off that's so crazy i'm
gonna draw my name on the other one
[Music]
hi
that's okay
there's a no
it's like a water gun but the water's
made out of plastic pellets
all right
be afraid be very afraid
just keep the threads clean
can't do that's it thanks no problem no
problem i'll walk you guys outside
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
you